mr president majority leader our
bipartisan
bicameral discussions on another major
pandemic rescue package continued
all night and this morning we're
winnowing down the remaining differences
i believe i can speak for all sides when
i say i hope and expect to have a final
agreement nailed down
in a matter of hours yesterday evening
our democratic colleagues agreed to
important language
authored by senator toomey
back in march in the cares act congress
funded several new emergency lending
facilities to be operated
by the federal reserve their purpose
was simple to backstop the basic
foundations of our economy and prevent
any kind of sweeping
financial paralysis our actions worked
the other historic relief that congress
passed combined with the existence of
these lending facilities staved off
systemic collapse american workers and
families still need much more help
but a total financial meltdown never
materialized
these new emergency lending facilities
were always intended to sunset at the
end
of this year senator toomey and our
democratic colleagues have landed on
compromised language that ensures
this will in fact happen
it also redirects the dormant money in
these accounts toward the urgent needs
of working americans and ensures that
these expiring programs cannot be simply
restarted or cloned
without another authorization from
congress
all while preserving both the
independence of the federal reserve and
the property
proper authority of congress
yet another example of good faith
bipartisan collaboration that has
defined our discussions
all week at this point we're down to the
last few differences that stand between
struggling americans and their major
rescue package
they need and deserve these days and
nights of negotiations have been
encouraging but our citizens need this
waiting game
to be over yesterday alone another
3 388 of my fellow kentuckians
tested positive for the coronavirus the
virus continues to spread throughout our
country thousands of americans are being
robbed of their lives
on a daily basis and while the
resilience of the american people have
brought along our economic recovery
recovery faster than expected it will
remain
both insufficient and tenuous until the
vaccines that will end this fight
have been distributed all across the
nation
for months literally months senate
republicans have been calling for
another
targeted package to reopen the
job-saving paycheck protection program
extend federal unemployment benefits
fund k-12 schools fund
vaccine distribution and get a lot more
help
onto the front lines as fast as possible
i'm relieved that we appear to be just
hours away from legislation
that will finally do that when we get
this done
congress will not deserve any special
praise not with this relief having
waited until late december
and not with some of our democratic
colleagues openly saying the reason they
finally changed their tune was they
finally got a president-elect of their
own party
when we when we finalize this measure
and pass it congress will only have done
our job
we will have finally done our duty in
getting more relief to those
who need it most let's make today the
day we join together
put differences aside and finally
get it done